♪ ♪
>> Hannity: IS BEEN 270 DAYS
SINCE WE ABANDON OUR FELLOW
AMERICANS IN AFGHANISTAN AND
SURRENDERED TO THE TALIBAN THAT
DOESN'T INCLUDE THOUSANDS OF
GREEN CARD HOLDERS THAT DOESN'T
INCLUDE OF COURSE ARE
AFGHANISTAN ALLIES MANY OF THEM
WHO HAVE BEEN MURDERED AND THE
TALIBAN IS NOW IN FULL CONTROL
RETURNING THERE RIGHT TO THEIR
HARD-LINE OPPRESSIVE RULE AS WE
PREDICTED SADLY, OPPRESSING
WOMEN AND YOUNG GIRLS
PIERS MORGAN GRILLED A TALIBAN
SPOKESPERSON ON HIS NEW SHOW
PIERS MORGAN UNCENSORED ABOUT
THESE MAJOR HUMAN RIGHTS
VIOLATION TAKE A LOOK AT THIS.
>> A GOOD SHOULD BE ENTITLED TO
GO TO SCHOOL THE SAME WAY A BOY
GOES TO SCHOOL YOU YOURSELF SAID
IN AUGUST LAST YEAR NOTHING BE
SCARED ABOUT.
>> THERE CAN BE SCHOOLS AND
EDUCATION FOR GIRLS.
>> LET ME TURN IF I MAY TO THE
ISSUE OF THE COMPULSORY
INSTRUCTION FOR ALL WOMEN IN
AFGHANISTAN WHERE A FULL BURQA
IF THEY GO OUTSIDE.
>> THEY ARE OBSERVING HER JOB.
>> Hannity: PIERS MORGAN
UNCENSORED AS IF THERE'S ANY
OTHER PEERS HEIRS NEW EPISODES
ON FOXNation.com.
WATCH VERY CLOSELY TO THIS
INTERVIEW WITH THE TALIBAN GUY.
I PREDICTED EXACTLY EVERYTHING
THAT WOULD HAPPEN.
IT WAS THE WORST DEBACLE
WITHDRAWAL EVER.
EVEN ANTHONY SET A HUNDRED AND
26 HE ACKNOWLEDGES AMERICANS ARE
TRAPPED BEHIND ENEMY LINES MANY
OF MY CONGRESSIONAL SOURCES TELL
ME THAT NUMBER IS MUCH HIGHER
AND WE HAVE THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE
THAT IF AMERICAN GREEN CARDS
ELIGIBLE TO BE IN THIS GREAT
COUNTRY THEY WERE TRAPPED BEHIND
ENEMY LINES AND ARE AFGHANISTAN
ALLIES WOULD NEVER ABANDON THEY
ARE NOW BEING TAKEN OUT IN THE
STREETS AND KILLED OR TAKEN A
NEVER TO BE SEEN AGAIN NEVER
MIND THE BILLIONS OF MILITARY
EQUIPMENT.
THE OLD TALIBAN IS THE NEW
TALIBAN, THIS IS EXACTLY WHAT
ANYONE WITH A BRAIN KNEW WOULD
HAPPEN.
>> EXACTLY RIGHT SEAN AND ITS
COMPLETE BETRAYAL OF AMERICANS
THAT ARE THERE AND REMAINED
THERE IN GREAT DANGER OF A TRAIL
THE INTERPRETERS AND
AFGHANISTAN'S EFFORTS IN
AFGHANISTAN BUT MOST OF ALL A
TERRIBLE BETRAYAL OF THE
AFGHANISTAN WOMEN.
THERE WAS SO DISINGENUOUS THEY
TOLD ME HE'S BUNCH OF BAREFACED
LIES AND EVENTUALLY TWO
DAUGHTERS TO THEY GO TO SCHOOL.
AND OF COURSE RIGHT THERE IS THE
HYPOCRISY WHICH IS RIDDLED
THROUGH THE TALIBAN EAT THOSE
ONE RULE FOR THEM AND THEIR
CHILDREN FOR THE FOUR.
ANY GIRL AFTER AGE ABOUT 12, 13
IS NOT GOING TO SCHOOL.
THEY MAY SAY ARE ENTITLED TO
HAVE THEIR EDUCATION STOLEN FROM
THEM AFTER TWO DECADES OF
GETTING USED TO HAVING ONE.
AND MANY OF THIS NEW RULE OF
AFGHANISTAN WOMEN THEY CAN'T GO
OUT THERE ACTUALLY TOLD THE STAY
AT HOME BUT THEY DO GO OUT THEY
CAN ONLY VIEW THEIR EYES ANY
BREACH OF THE RULE THE MALE
RELATIVES OR THE MALE EMPLOYER
MAY BE HELD RESPONSIBLE THEY ARE
THE ENFORCEMENTS AND IF THEY
DON'T ENFORCE IT THAN THEY
THEMSELVES FACE IMPRISONMENT.
SEER TAKING REALLY STEP BACK TO
THE DARK MEDIEVAL AGES WITH
THIS.
TO THE VERY WORST OF TALIBAN
1.0.
THERE IS NO TALIBAN 2.0.
JUST AS BAD AS THEY WERE BEFORE
AND THE ABANDONMENT OF THESE
PEOPLE I THINK THIS COULD BE ON
JOE BIDEN'S CONSCIOUS.
BECAUSE IT WAS A CATASTROPHIC
FAILURE OF FOREIGN POLICY TO
JUST UP AND LEAVE AND BASICALLY
HAND THE COUNTRY BACK TO THE
TALIBAN WOLVES.
>> Hannity: I THINK HE DID A
REALLY GOOD JOB OF THAT WHAT I
DON'T UNDERSTAND IS WHERE OUR
WOMEN'S RIGHTS GROUPS WHERE IS
THE AND COMMUNITY BECAUSE IF
YOU'RE OR THEY WERE MURDER YOU
WHERE THE HUMAN RIGHTS ACTIVISTS
AND ALL THIS BECAUSE WE DON'T
AGREE ON EVERYTHING BUT WE AGREE
ON THIS.
IT'S GOD GIVEN RIGHTS FROM GOD.
>> NOTHING WE HEAR A LOT FROM
BIG CORPORATIONS LIKE DISNEY
WHEN THEY WANT VIRTUE SIGNAL
DOWN IN FLORIDA ABOUT
SEX EDUCATION TO YOUNG KIDS BUT
NOT A WORD FROM THEM ABOUT THE
OPPRESSION OF MILLIONS OF
AFGHANISTAN WOMEN IN AFGHANISTAN
BECAUSE OF COURSE IT WAS A
DEMOCRAT PRESIDENT THAT CREATED
THIS FIASCO.
THAT SHOWS THE POLITICAL BIAS
FOR ALL THESE CORPORATIONS NONE
OF THEM DARE TO SPEAK OUT ABOUT
THIS.
SUPREME COURT